Now, one thing I'll be doing throughout all my lessons,
is I'm going to start off each lesson with a list of objectives for that lesson.
And then we'll try to see if we can match and
have you learn about those specific things in that specific lesson.
The four specific objectives for this lesson are, is one again, for
you to start thinking about a digital image and look at representations of
an image with, in terms of pixels, and at the resolution of that image.
I will cover basics of how we would actually represent that image as in
a discrete form using a matrix, or in a continuous form as a function.
We will be looking at the other foundations of grayscale and color images.
And I'll also be touching on how digital images and the file formats and
stuff like that are used.
What is actually in those files that you've gotten used to
seeing on your cameras and your computers?